Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Buongiorno a tutti.
Sono lieta di essere qua.
Sono abituata, devo dire,
più a fare che a dire,
quindi se mi incespico mi perdonerete,
anzi vi canterò perdono.
Volevo dire, parto da qui.
La mia vita e la musica
sono sempre andate a braccetto.
Ho cominciato come interprete
e poi come produttore discografico,
come editore e ho
il privilegio di lavorare
vicino agli autori, artisti,
insomma il mondo della creatività.
Parlerò dei talenti, di come
ce lo si trova davanti,
di come lo si scopre,
ma soprattutto vorrei parlarvi
della costruzione
del percorso artistico,
che è un lavoro che si fa,
che è tangibile,
ma che non si vede
e che è un lavoro molto importante,
veramente molto importante.
Come lo farò?
Lo farò grazie alla collaborazione
di un giovane artista che è qui
con me e che insieme
cercheremo di mettere in scena
questo percorso.
È Marco Sbarbati, che è qui con me,
che vorrei cercare di invitare
qui sul palcoscenico.
Vorrei farvi notare
che è l'unico uomo, credo,
che salga sul palco quest'oggi, no?
Allora, una volta il mio primo
incontro con l'artista
avveniva nel mio ufficio,
ma le cose cambiano
e nonostante i problemi che la rete
ha causato alla nostra industria
ci dà anche molte opportunità.
Ci siamo conosciuti con Marco
nel 2012 in un hangout
che è stato organizzato
da Sugar e da Google,
praticamente era un concorso
che mi consentiva
di mettermi in contatto,
di relazionarmi con nuovi artisti.
Possiamo passare il video,
per favore...
Ciao Marco.
Buonasera,
volevo innanzitutto ringraziarla
per essere qua, perché è molto bella
questa situazione di hangout.
Io sono un cantautore, ho 26 anni
e suono un po' ovunque,
mi piace moltissimo
anche sedermi in strada.
La mia domanda è: lei crede che sia
un po' la gente che vuole
ascoltare sempre la stessa cosa,
o a volte anche le case discografiche,
magari oggi,
vista la situazione della musica,
hanno un po' paura a rischiare
in qualcosa di nuovo?
Beh, un po' è vero che la situazione
è tale per cui mentre prima,
come dicevo,
si facevano, nel nostro caso,
dodici progetti l'anno,
oggi ne facciano uno all'anno
e questo purtroppo
è un impoverimento,
ma questa è una conseguenza
di una situazione, purtroppo, viziosa
che si è creata
per tutta una serie di altre,
insomma, situazioni, nelle quali
purtroppo siamo obbligati a navigare.
Però io invece credo che bisogna
lavorare sull'unicità.
E questo lo credo ancora, devo dire.
Io, non so se avete visto,
ero un po' imbarazzata,
perché in realtà,
per come sono fatta io,
io vorrei aiutare tutti i ragazzi,
ma questo non è possibile ovviamente
e poi spiegherò dopo perché.
Comunque Marco mi ha incuriosito
e come voi sapete
per capire, anche per cercare di capire
tra le righe un talento, con la rete
è tutto troppo distante,
c'è bisogno del contatto umano.
Marco nel frattempo mi aveva scritto
una lettera, tra l'altro molto carina
- tra l'altro la lettera
conteneva anche dei testi -
e mi diceva in quella lettera:
vorrei tanto venire da lei
e vorrei poter cantare queste canzoni,
perché volevo che lei mi sentisse
e si rendesse conto di cosa io posso fare.
E a questo punto,
io l'ho visto Marco, si è presentato
con la chitarra e devo dire
che mi ha un po' stupito.
Ho sentito questa voce molto consistente
e ho pensato
che quelle sue interpretazioni
e questo suo lavorare sulle piazze
avesse consentito a lui,
siccome sulle piazze
ci sono le persone
che non vengono lì per ascoltarti,
no, sono persone di passaggio,
quindi ho pensato che questa sua voce
che adesso voi sentite,
poi ve ne parlerò ancora meglio,
ho pensato che questa sua voce
richiamasse proprio
queste persone che erano distratte, no?
Che tu in qualche modo
dovevi attrarre, con questa voce.
Ci fai sentire una delle canzoni
che mi hai fatto sentire in ufficio
e - un pezzettino, ovviamente,
non possiamo di più purtroppo -
Backwards per esempio?
Certo, assolutamente.
Tell me you want more of my lips
tell me you want more of my tricks
none of us has followed any rules
I should have let you know that I was
burning as a star for you
but not in your sky
Grazie mille.
Non so che cosa ne pensiate voi,
però io sono rimasta
molto colpita, lo dicevo anche prima,
da questa voce,
una voce consistente, che personalmente
mi ha fatto risvegliare
un mondo di musica
che non ascoltavo più, come quella
di James Taylor,
Tracy Chapman per esempio
e poi però lo guardavo mentre cantava,
adesso lui è seduto
ma allora era in piedi
nel mio ufficio e devo dire
che mi ha colpito molto
questa sua sincerità.
Quello che raccontava e che diceva,
che cantava era tutt'uno,
proprio in un modo così sincero,
quasi disarmante.
È inutile dirvi che mi ha emozionato
e che cosa avviene
quando mi succede questo,
avviene che comincia il mio lavoro,
cioè quello che non si vede.
Naturalmente il mio lavoro ha un inizio
che è legato anche alla scommessa,
la scommessa è un rischio:
cioè - tu decidi,
non sai come va a finire, no,
però è qualcosa che senti che devi fare.
Quando smisi di cantare e mi promisi,
mi feci una promessa, che io
avrei sempre cercato
di aiutare un talento,
se fossi stata certa
che ci fosse un talento, ad emergere.
Questa è una cosa
che mi sono sempre portata con me.
Poi mi piacciono le sfide
e anche sulle sfide, insomma,
è più forte di me:
se sento qualcosa che mi piace
non faccio tanti calcoli,
si parte e si va.
Il passo successivo è valorizzare
musicalmente le potenzialità di Marco.
Come si fa, si fa perché lui
scrive le sue canzoni
e quindi bisogna fare attenzione
a non cambiare questa sua direzione,
per cui occorre trovare una persona,
si chiama produttore artistico,
che possa aiutare Marco
in questo percorso,
cercare di migliorare.
Ciò che lui fa
esattamente con la chitarra
e con la voce non è sufficiente,
dobbiamo "arredare" questa canzone;
ma ci vuole la persona giusta.
Io conosco una persona con la quale
abbiamo fatto tanti altri lavori
ed è una persona molto capace,
si chiama Corrado Rustici.
È un italiano però vive
in America da trent'anni.
Abbiamo fatto sentire i provini a Corrado,
Corrado ha sentito le stesse vibrazioni
che ho sentito io,
abbiamo proceduto
alla scelta del repertorio,
abbiamo sentito le preproduzioni e poi
finalmente Marco è volato,
è andato a San Francisco.
A San Francisco lui ha lavorato
e grazie alla rete
e grazie anche al fuso orario
- ci sono nove ore di differenza -
loro lavoravano di giorno,
la sera attraverso il file audio
noi ascoltavamo
quello che facevamo e questo lavoro
è seguito, è diventato,
è cresciuto e praticamente
dopo venti giorni, forse poco più,
abbiamo sentito
queste sue canzoni "arredate",
come direbbe Paolo Conte,
con uno studio,
con una messa a punto in certi momenti,
si individua la gemma
che c'è all'interno della canzone
e si cerca di metterla a fuoco,
affinché l'ascoltatore,
quando sente la canzone,
capisca quel momento e si ricordi.
Allora, vogliamo sentire
che cosa è accaduto
in questi giorni di studio
a San Francisco,
quella canzone che avete sentito prima
Marco la farà qui arredata di una base,
quindi canterà dal vivo sulla base
ed è la prima volta che questa canzone
verrà fatta,
praticamente, qui al TEDx,
è la prima volta
che Marco esegue questa canzone
sul palcoscenico, dal vivo. (Applausi)
Tell me you want more of my lips
tell me you want more of my tricks
none of us has followed any rules
I should have let you know that I was
burning as a star for you
but not in your sky
Everything I've ever known
is now turning against me
backwards I'm falling
everything I've ever learned
is holding down my feet
backwards I'm going,
I've been whirling in this mess,
like every time.
You're just too blind,
you're just too blind.
Everything I've ever known
is now turning against me
backwards I'm falling
Everything I've ever learned
is holding down my feet
backwards I'm going
I've been whirling in this mess,
like every time.
You're just too blind.
(Applausi)
Grazie mille.
Che bello, bellissimo...
Molto, grazie! (Applausi)
È la prima volta che canta
sul palcoscenico. Bello. (Applausi)
Il risultato mi sembra convincente.
Comunque, adesso che cosa dobbiamo fare,
sempre rispetto
al nostro percorso del lavoro?
Dobbiamo pensare a strategie di marketing,
dobbiamo fare comunicazione,
dobbiamo cercare ogni modo
per far arrivare questo nostro talento,
la creatività di Marco
al più largo pubblico possibile.
A questo punto che cosa facciamo a Marco,
gli facciamo gli auguri,
gli facciamo gli auguri
che questo disco possa essere
un disco, il primo disco
di una lunga carriera,
così, come è accaduto
a tanti altri miei artisti,
che in questi ultimi anni,
in questi ultimi vent'anni
ho avuto la fortuna di scoprire
e l'onore di aiutare ad emergere.
(Segue una lista di artisti
scoperti e promossi da Caselli)
(Applausi)
Beh, va detto che anche loro
hanno cominciato come Marco:
tutto è accaduto nel mio ufficio,
eccetto che con Elisa che lei era
in un piccolo anfiteatro,
ma per il resto
tutto il percorso è sempre lo stesso.
Ogni volta però c'è sempre
una cosa diversa,
non succede esattamente così
tutte le volte:
ogni artista ha una sua personalità,
un suo mondo,
ha un suo talento, quindi diciamo
che gli attori intorno cambiano.
Occorre fare attenzione,
cercare di non sopraffare
quella che è la loro creatività,
la loro originalità e questo
è un lavoro, diciamo,
molto molto importante.
Comunque, sempre c'è un'avventura
in questo nostro lavoro,
cioè non sei mai certa
che tutto questo che tu fai
avrà poi un ritorno.
Perché è così, perché tu rischi.
D'altro canto è giusto che sia così,
è talmente bello questo nostro lavoro,
ci dà talmente tante soddisfazioni
che solo il fatto di poterlo fare,
la passione che hai
per fare questo lavoro
ti rigenera tanta energia,
è veramente bello di per sé,
però l'unica amarezza che hai
è che tu vorresti fare molto di più,
vorresti essere molto più disponibile
per poter essere un gradino
per qualcun altro
e per tanti altri.
Purtroppo noi siamo costretti
ad essere un gradino
per pochi, purtroppo.
Però, per riassumere un po'
tutto il nostro percorso
che prima ho cercato di mettere in scena,
vorrei parlare di queste sette parole.
C'è stato un incontro,
lo stupore dell'artista,
cioè lo stupore che ho provato
quando ho sentito Marco,
il rischio, la scommessa, la sfida,
l'avventura - l'ultima parola è vittoria?
Punto di domanda. Non si sa.
Per cambiare questi punti
interrogativi in punti esclamativi
abbiamo bisogno
di voi, del pubblico e anche
di un po' di fortuna. (Applausi)
Vorrei richiamare
la vostra attenzione
sulla necessità di rimettere in moto
un circuito virtuoso,
dove i guadagni generati dai successi
possono essere reinvestiti per creare
e sostenere nuovi artisti,
affinché la creatività
possa continuare ad espandersi
trovando nuovi orizzonti.
Questo è possibile solo se parliamo
il linguaggio della verità senza trucchi
e a questo punto io so che vado a toccare
un tasto dolente, però lo faccio,
è un tasto sensibile
ma lo faccio perché sono convinta
di quello che dico
e cioè dobbiamo rispettare
e difendere il diritto d'autore,
che è il vero motore,
è il paladino della creatività
e della cultura in generale,
è nato per difendere
la libertà di espressione
e la possibilità di vivere
del proprio lavoro.
Il diritto d'autore
esiste da trecento anni,
è il motore di benessere
non solo per chi crea
ma anche per tutta la società.
Oggi questo circuito virtuoso
si è interrotto
e questo è un grosso rischio,
ma può essere rimesso in moto
solo a una condizione,
che si rispetti di più il lavoro
di tutte le industrie creative,
non solo la musica, ed il suo indotto,
ma anche gli autori
delle opere letterarie,
grafiche, del cinema e della TV.
Se non riusciremo a difendere
la nostra creatività
e le nostre eredità culturali,
noi non riaccenderemo
il motore di sviluppo
e di crescita economica.
Concludendo, lasciamo alle tecnologie
tutto lo spazio
che rivendicano e che meritano,
ma qui ci vuole
davvero un'alleanza di tutte
le industrie creative europee,
ci vuole un bello scatto di orgoglio
che ridia speranza
e lavoro ai nostri giovani talenti
di oggi e di domani.
(Applausi)